we have a voicemail number and that
number is 219 to David P
here's a great voicemail from the Eggman
you know I spoke about my time up north
in uh the Hudson Valley recently in New
York and I mentioned you go north you go
west it gets more and more conservative
the Eggman called in who lives way out
there and he said David the Hudson
Valley is nothing you should see what
goes on where I live
hey Dave
like how you describe New York and how
he said the further north or west you
get in New York state the further
conservative yes it does I live in
Western New York Dave I live a half hour
from Niagara Falls okay that's on
Western New York I'm well not that close
but
we are so uh Western New York I call it
West Virginia New York right there's
more Dale Earnhardt 03
NASCAR and Trump Flags around here than
you would even see in Florida yeah
absolutely insane really there are a ton
of Confederate flags
you would think that we're in the South
so the caller from Texas yesterday who
told you about all the right-wing
anti-trump uh let's go Brandon Flags he
described West Virginia New York when
you talk about the Hudson Valley I don't
think you have any idea how red it is up
here
I grow a large beard and drive an old
pickup truck just to be Incognito just
so they won't kill me for being a Jew oh
God Shalom brother yeah so I mean
obviously the area Eggman is describing
is very different you know Hudson lots
of Jewish folks gay folks in Hudson
Valley uh and no need to be hiding
Incognito the way that the Eggman
describes hiding as a Jewish man in uh
in Western New York so yes I I am aware
that Hudson Valley is not nearly as
right-wing as the areas that Eggman is
talking about but uh yeah no the further
you get from New York City in New York
state the wackier and wackier that it
gets we have a fantastic bonus show for
you today Chuck Schumer is uh going to
be holding a same-sex marriage vote why
why isn't this a settled issue well
there's a PR reason why it's being done
and we're going to talk about it on the
bonus show secondly we are going to dive
deep into the Jackson Mississippi Water
Crisis and we're going to tie this into
economic Justice we're going to tie this
into climate change it is a major story
it is another major Water Crisis many
people familiar with Flint Michigan this
is now another Water Crisis in Jackson
Mississippi and thirdly there is a
California school district asking the
families of the students
to rent out rooms to the teachers in the
school district
what why is that happening it may or may
not surprise you all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show you can
sign up at joinpakman.com and get
instant access to the bonus show you can
also if you're waiting for the exact
perfect time to get a membership for All
of the Stars to align for there to be a
so-called double rainbow and point to a
membership on both ends of the rainbow
um get on my newsletter at
davidpackman.com because on 919
September 19th we are doing a massive
membership discount and you need only be
on my newsletter to be notified alright
so I would love to see you on the bonus
show today but if you're waiting for the
919 special I also understand and either
way we'll be back with a new show for
you tomorrow